I like to start my talks off with some
expectations so that you know whether or
not to get out your phone and check
Twitter so this talk I'm going to go
over the typical life cycle of a
component not the component life cycle
and you'll see what I mean in a little
bit we're gonna look at how patterns can
simplify our components and and in what
ways our components can get really and
and how our patterns can simplify those
we're gonna look at the composability of
reactive why one of the reasons why we
love react so much and I'm going to give
you a challenge so prepare yourselves
I'm not going to be talking about how to
implement these patterns I'm going to be
referencing a bunch of patterns that you
may or may not have heard of before
mostly this talk is to inspire you to
learn about these patterns and apply and
then apply them to your components to
make your make happier components and be
happier using those two components so if
you do want to learn about this stuff
definitely like learn react I've got a
free course about that and then once you
got react down solid I've got another
course on egghead about these patterns
specifically so if you want to learn
about these like the how for this stuff
then then that's a good place to go you
ready to get started
okay now that the kind of boring stuff
is over okay so we're going to be
working with this autocomplete component
or this accordion component so I can
open up two different items in the
accordion and it like it's pretty
typical and it allows me to ooh okay
it's not going to play again just
remember that don't look away because
you'll miss the the video playback but
yeah so I can open up each one of these
and like you build this component you're
like sweet I've solved my use case I'm
going to package that up and capsulate
that logic make an accordion component
and then you just pass items to it they
have a title and content it's perfect
right we've all built a component like
or or you built the components similar
to these and then somebody comes around
to you and says hey listen I saw that
you have this accordion component it's
really awesome
and one of the things we love about
react is how easy it is to share code
between different places in the amp
right so could I maybe use that
accordion component you say yeah totally
like you just import accordion from my
components accordion and then you just
pass these items they have to be
structured like this and they say yeah
that's fine
I have one problem though my accordion
needs to be rendered a little
differently I need it to render the
content above the items say yeah yeah
okay yeah I can do that so you get into
your render method you say if above like
this draw props dot above then we'll
render the content above and then yeah
that's fine not a big deal and they say
great thanks this is working so well and
then somebody comes over to that person
and says hey that's a cool accordion
where did you get that and I said oh
yeah this this person over here who
built it and they come to you and say
hey I need to have an accordion in my
apt in my part of the app too except
I've got a slightly different use case I
need it to appear to the right you're
like okay yeah that's just some like
flexbox magic and yeah I can make that
work and so you build that and you say
okay now I have a write prompt so they
start prompt start right then I'll do my
flexbox magic and then somebody else
comes and they say hey I need it to the
left and so now okay I got a left prop
and then you remember something that you
heard on Twitter once and you think oh
wait I've got some impossible States I
could have a Prophet's left it's true
and right is true and now what do I do
so you refactor everything well you
don't refactor you actually make a
breaking change and you say okay now I'm
going to have a position prop position
that is left position is okay now we're
good and and the functional people will
not hate me anymore so that's good so
then somebody says hey you know that
accordion that you built like the way
that and like before they even talk you
say don't ask me to change how its
rendered please don't ask me how they
say no no like the original way it's
rendered is totally fine but I have a
logic difference for my use case so for
mine I can only open one at a time so if
somebody tries to open another one it
should close
you say okay yeah that's that's just a
you know another prop single is true and
then in my handle item or handle
accordion title quick I'll just do an if
statement and okay yeah that'll work and
now you've got a little bit more logic
in your your event handler there and
then somebody says I also have a logic
change I need to prevent people from
closing all of them so they can close
them but not the last one and you say
okay yeah I just I I can do that
like that's just another if statement
but you're starting to feel a little bit
uncomfortable about things you're like
originally this thing was like 30 lines
of code and now it's it's grown to like
300 lines of code I'm not I'm not super
excited about this there it's making me
feel a little uncomfortable and somebody
who says hey oh and we add the prevent
clothes problem and somebody says hey I
want to do both of those things so I I
can only have one open at a time and I
can't close it you say oh yeah sweet oh
thank you I don't have to make any
changes you just have to provide both
those props and then it'll work okay but
then this is when developers start to
cry somebody comes and says hey that
single prevent closed accordion that
actually is like exactly like a tabs UI
logically it just looks a lot of
different so do you mind if I I can make
a pull request but what if I built a the
render ability for a tabs UI and you're
like no please and they say no no I
it'll be so easy it's just an if
statement how many times have you heard
that just an if statement but in the
render method I'll just do if and you're
crying if this stuff props aw tabs then
return this dot render according or
render tabs and I'll just have another
method it'll won't mess up your render
method at all just be another render
method okay and you need to ship stuff
right like you've got customers and and
so you say okay fine yes and then
somebody comes and says oh I want to
render the tabs below oh shoot
and now you're sobbing and
you eventually just create a new
component right just like you build it I
don't need that my use case so this this
is what I mean when I say the lifecycle
of a component how many people have
experienced something similar to this
yes
okay I'm glad that I'm not alone it's
nice to have camaraderie there so you
don't have to actually see exactly what
all these props are but you get the idea
what happens is these use cases start
piling up and people start saying hey I
want my accordion items to have it
disabled so that I can disable an
accordion and then I want my I want the
open trigger to be on focus rather than
an click or on press or whatever I need
to style things a little different so
can I have some class names cost named
props and and you just start piling
things that like render expand all
button and yeah that was that was the
source of more tears so they're like
it's more than just the like I don't
like having all this complexity add it
to my component there are actual
technical problems with building
components in this way
first off for the web a bundle size it
makes a big difference
um and and for native as well
performance can be a drain so like you
started with this 30 line component it's
really really simple didn't really have
much conditional logic and it's growing
and growing and growing to the point
where you're like maybe I should just
write a one-off because that thing's too
complex for my use case and so now you
have a bunch of code in there that you
don't actually need or use in your
situation another problem is the
maintenance overhead of having to think
about so many different use cases is
really a drain it's not a lot of fun to
deal with that yeah that's no fun I'm
sure you know what I mean and then as
the complexity of your component grows
the possibility of bugs sneaking in
increases also I think there's like a
exponential curve on that and so that
also makes me really sad
and the API this like originally it was
just like one prop items but now we've
like as many props as you can imagine
when I was researching or like looking
for examples for this talk I asked on
Twitter what's the most props that
anybody has seen on our component show
somebody showed me an open-source
component that had 125 props it was a
reusable component ya know I mean it was
a pretty complex estate picker but yeah
that yeah that just makes me cry twice
so somebody on that on that same thread
said her name is Jen Creighton
I call this into proc ellipse yes this
isn't a proc ellipse um I thought that
was great let's make that a thing
hashtag apocalypse all right advance the
real so all those examples that you saw
before what if I told you that were they
were all based on the same 37 line
component using some of these patterns
and this is it all right I'll be honest
I I did like scrunch up some of the
lines so it'd be shorter so that's why
this one's like extra long prettier
would have but you know so yeah it's
it's actually pretty like relatively
straightforward we're using a couple
patterns in here that you may not be
super familiar with so that's why we
have this internal set state and this
changes object thing and and and then
we're using render props here that's
that's a big piece like all of the logic
that we're adding most of that was going
into our render method some of it was
happening in our handle item quake but
what we're doing here is it's called
inversion of control
so we're saying I don't want to make all
the decisions off I'll come up with some
good defaults but I'm going to give you
some control over how this stuff is
managed and that opens up a whole world
of possibilities that that inversion of
control means that you're giving up
responsibility for certain things but by
by giving up that responsibility and
handing it off to the user they can add
the code that they need for their
specific use case so it's a little bit
harder to use
for simple use cases but because of Reax
composability model it actually can is a
really nice way to build components so
let's get a couple of examples here
you're going to need to watch because I
can't play the video over again
apparently which is unfortunate so don't
blink
isn't that like from a movie or
something okay so here we have our
standard accordion and to change it to
an above accordion when that person
comes and says hey I want it above
accordion you just say you just take my
standard accordion copy-paste it and you
move stuff you just you literally move
the contents above the button and that's
all you need to do and they say awesome
I can copy like 20 lines of code no
problem just move stuff that's great
so that handles the rendered things
about what about the person who came and
said hey let's render things to the left
is that cool and you say hey yeah just
take the person who had their above code
take that code and copy that and add a
variant to the accordion item and then
you just change the emoji right and that
variant will control like that that
accordion item will just have some a
little bit of logic in it to control
what with the CSS or the styles to apply
to that element okay cool and then
somebody says hey I want the right I'm
going from left to right so take the
left and then just swap the content
again swap the con and the button and
now I have a really awesome right
experience so you're getting some code
duplication here and you could abstract
some of this stuff into a single
component to handle some of these use
cases without making the base component
any more complex and so so that's
awesome people opt into the complexity
that that they want and then somebody
says hey I want to take that standard
component but I want to add the like
single click behavior so you say great
I've implemented the state reducer
pattern and so now all you need to do is
write a like four line reducer function
that will control that that logic and
you just add that state reducer that
single reducer to the props and matt
deqin sues that now behave
the way that you want it to and then
somebody says that well that that's
single reducer isn't doing what I want I
want to prevent clicks and so you say
okay yeah just swap that single reducer
for the prevent closed reducer and now
you're set and then that person comes it
says I want both can I have both and you
say yes you write this 10 line combined
reducers function and you can combine
the prevent closed and single reducers
together and to get that state behavior
cool and then the taps people come and
they're like hey listen I noticed that
state reducer think and I have my tabs
and you say absolutely yes you can in
fact let's write a taps component right
now here it is
you have your state reducer as a prop
and then all the other props and then
you combine the custom state reducer
that anybody using the tabs component
can also have their own reducer
with the single and prevent clothes
reducers and then you just pour it on
the props they can render it however
they want and it works great so now
anybody using the tabs component is is
actually using that same underlying
logic from the accordion because lots of
this this stuff is exactly the same and
then they get the benefit of your your
state reducer so cool let's see what
that looks like in practice somebody
built their standard tabs and then they
want to add a the swap it from below to
above then you just take that standard
tabs accordion or that standard tabs and
swap the items and the buttons and magic
ensues and through the whole course of
all this stuff nobody needed to come and
ask you questions about how to use your
component or change your component we
didn't have to change your component at
all and we continue working on other
really fun components like date pickers
that don't have 125 props so this is
great I I'm really excited by these
patterns on I so I how many people here
have used downshift or heard of down
ship ok
I said used or heard of because I'm
going to assume you've all used it so
great so in shift is an autocomplete
component where I learned about and
implemented all these patterns works in
react native really super but
I just want to give you a word of
caution about these patterns one
question people often ask me about the
react component patterns and I'm always
talking about is are these just for
highly reusable components and the
answer is it's more obvious when to use
this for highly reusable components but
that's not just what these are useful
for this is also useful for separating
concerns you've got your logic
components and then you've got your
presentation components really easy to
separate those with some of these
patterns and and being able to do that
can really enhance the productivity of
engineers working on your codebase so
here's the word of caution what if this
was all you ever needed like in the
first place you you build out this
really highly complex component and then
this simple one on top of it to do all
the rendering and if this is all you
ever needed then you probably wasted a
bunch of time and and added some
complexity every abstraction comes with
complexity you cannot get around that a
function comes with the cost and so you
need to determine whether the benefits
outweigh the cost and so I as much as I
love these patterns I don't use them in
every component that I build I will
definitely build one-off components that
it you know just that original accordion
it's 30 lines long it's very simple and
I'm happy with that and then somebody
comes with a different use case and I'll
add an if statement that's like there's
nothing wrong with an if statement
although I kind of prefer to Nerys but
whatever so like feel free to to add a
couple use cases only when you you
notice that hey this could actually be
made a lot simpler if we change this to
use some other patterns that you can add
that complexity and feel a little bit
better about the the cost and benefits
so the the whole point of this talk is I
want to encourage you to learn about and
use patterns that simplify your API the
API of your component as well as the
implementation so some of the patterns
that we looked at and some of the
patterns I'm excited about render props
state reducers compound components we
didn't look at those
but those accordions are pretty good use
case for compound component components
control props really really powerful the
provider pattern and there are a bunch
more and one of the cool things that I
like about software and one of the
interesting things is that we're always
rediscovering things that they knew like
three decades ago but we're applying it
to what we have today and I think that's
pretty cool so let's let's go do some
research play around with things and
rediscover some more patterns that we
can apply to our components to make our
component API is an implementation
simpler that's all I have for you thank
you very much
[Applause]